[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver dans le 7-8 loisirs vous était
sorti dans le département on commence au
jt avec le sommaire de ce numéro pour
les vacances la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet se transforme en jeu
d'évasion grandeur nature un escape game
sur le thème de la ferme et de
l'agroécologie plus de détails dans ce
magazine
la maison d'édition rue du monde fête
ses 20 ans autour d'une exposition à
versailles six illustrateur
emblématiques ont été réunies une
invitation au voyage
en tout la poésie en forme hélène poker
nous parlera des vacances au château de
breteuil et ses traditionnels ateliers
costumes
cette fois le thème porte sur le
carnaval de venise découverte à suivre
et on commence par du sport ce samedi
aura lieu une compétition de danse
sportive le grand prix de danses latines
et standards de la ville de versailles
une centaine de couples venus de toute
la france vont s'affronter dès 11 heures
oslo au gymnase mont boron
on écoute un mot du président du comité
départemental propos recueillis par
mélanie poker
le public va pouvoir voir des danses
latines et des danses standards qui ont
été popularisées depuis l'émission danse
avec les stars et vous pourrez également
découvrir d'autres styles de danse car
nous avons décidé pendant cette soirée
d'ouvrir la possibilité aux associations
du département des yvelines qu'il
souhaitait de nous présenter leurs
activités
donc vous aurez également de la country
de la danse orientale et des danses
irlandaises
il y aura du haut niveau notamment dans
standard il ya le couple vice-champion
de france de danses standards qui est
qui est inscrit nous avons même trois
des dix meilleurs couples français en
dans ce standard qui seront présents
elie le loisir de 50 ans ne vienne
accueille actuellement de nouveaux
pensionnaires il s'agit plus précisément
de ceux du cirque zavatta la compagnie a
planté son chapiteau jusqu'au 15 février
l'occasion de découvrir une quarantaine
d'animaux et des performe des
performances artistiques acrobatie et
clowneries les spectacles ont lieu tous
les jours en écoute un mot du
responsable les têtes au micro de
mickaël hentze d'euros et alice
deschamps
nous avons des numéros à grandes
stations grandes sensations comme la
roue de la mort on a un joli numéro 6
qui très original
pour les jeunes cette année la femme la
z après on a des clowns des acrobates
ont à chameaux lamas et watusi dgac
on a un spectacle d'une heure 45
vraiment varié il n'y a pas d'âge au
cirque aussi bien les petits comme les
comme les seniors on a vraiment vraiment
pas d'âge et c'est ce qu'on essaye de
rechercher ce qu'on veut toucher tous
types d'âge pour que toutes les familles
peuvent s'amuser pendant les 1h45 du
spectacle et si pendant les vacances
d'hiver vous devenez un véritable
détective c'est ce que propose la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet
jusqu'au 19 février
un jeu d'évasion grandeur nature sur le
thème quand je serai grand je serai un
bios fermiers les détails avec emilie
rue l animatrice à la bergerie nationale
au micro de nicolas landry on va
demander au public de rester dans un
endroit précis pendant environ un quart
d'heure vingt minutes et d'essayer de
résoudre une énigme pour avoir le droit
de sortir du bâtiment et d'aller
découvrir le reste de la ferme ou
d'aller faire une autre énigme dans un
autre bâtiment parce que l'avait rappelé
quand elle est arrivée ce matin elle a
remarqué d'alain qui avait mangé tout le
train qui avait dans le sang on va
absolument du leur compte parce que il
va avoir mal au ventre et bientôt le
swahili que je le mets dans l'infirmerie
derrière c'est que je alaa sont
sa petite histoire on a essayé de rendre
vivant un petit peu ces énigmes donc
par exemple au niveau de la basse cour
ça va être l'aviculteur qui va se cogner
la tête et qui a oublié le nom de son
coq donc les enfants doivent retrouver
le nom du coq pour l'animation des
chevaux
on va avoir des charades les enfants
devront trouver les réponses aux
charades tout sa mise en forme sous
forme d' une interro surprise d'un
professeur toutes les réponses aux
charades sont bien entendu 1
en rapport avec les chevaux au niveau
des vaches ça va être
donne à notre chien à la ferme qui a
mangé le cahier d'un élève il la dèche
qui la déchire il va falloir rassembler
un petit peu tous les morceaux du cahier
pour trouver la réponse à l'énigme et au
niveau des moutons c'est
un mouton qui a mangé un saut de grains
il va falloir retrouver quel est ce
mouton chaque étape innocente un mouton
et à la fin on a le coupable et c'est le
vétérinaire tu veux savoir lequel pour
pas pour voir lequel va être malade on
était plutôt sur un thème de cirque et
carnaval pendant les vacances de février
on a voulu changer et plus axé sur un
thème qui se rapporte à la ferme mais
faut quand même regarder soul là on a
surtout axé les les escape game sur les
métiers donc on a un jeu au niveau
des chevaux avec le métier du cocher un
jeu au niveau des vaches au niveau des
moutons et au niveau des poules toujours
en mettant en avant un petit peu le
l'agriculture biologique et l'agro
écologie plein de petits bouts comme ça
qu'elle a mis partout dans le bâtiment
donc il va falloir m'aider si vous
voulez bien à retrouver tous les petits
morceaux grand cahier c'est un peu
novateur on est les seuls en terre en
ferme pédagogique et dans la région un
peu à tester ça on va on va espérer
comme à chaque vacances entre 300 et 400
personnes par jour ce serait bien on va
dire s'est dessinée à peu près aux
enfants de
4 à 10 ans donc tous les après midi ça
commencera à 14h30 là
le dernier on va dire départ des skins
game se fait à 16 heures le ciné je sais
une séance à 15h15 d'une séance à 16h15
la kermesse se sera en continu tout au
long de l'après midi et puis à 16h30 on
peut retrouver comme d'habitude la
traite des vaches et 17h laissons aux
animaux à la basse cour
ce qu'on leur apprend
c'est
comment être responsable dans
l'environnement et comment
bien agir dans le
dans la nature et dans la vie en règle
générale l'objectif c'est de venir et de
d'apprendre en s'amusant puisqu'il ya
toujours quand même un peu
d'apprentissage sur chaque métier et
puis surtout de le travail un petit peu
en équipe puisque là les enfants je
pense seront aidés de leurs parents ou
de leurs ventes a enfin des
accompagnateurs qui seront avec eux et
puis ça permet de s'amuser en famille et
pendant les vacances les éditions rue du
monde fêtent leurs 20 ans autour d'une
exposition au carré à la farine de
versailles six illustrateur emblématique
présentent leurs oeuvres
de nombreux ateliers sont également
mises en place pour découvrir leur
univers
un reportage réalisé avec mathilde et
demi des livres pour interroger et
imaginer le monde c'est la devise des
éditions rue du monde installé à voisins
le bretonneux la maison fête cette année
ses 20 ans pour cet anniversaire une
librairie versaillaise a souhaité rendre
hommage à ces illustrateurs en discutant
avec l'éditeur on a décidé ensemble
proposer ces six illustrateurs qui sont
tout à fait représentatif de l'esprit
deux images ce qui moi me touche c'est
que ce côté très engagé de leur travail
que ce soit dans la couleur la forme ou
une petite folie
par exemple je trouve que de passé
énormément de temps à dessiner les
oiseaux en costume il une certaine
poésie l'habillement qui me plaît
beaucoup
des personnages déguisés de vanessa hié
aux couleurs vives de laurent corvaisier
le visiteur embarque dans un univers à
mi-chemin entre fantastique et réalité
réalisés à l'encré de chine les oeuvres
2 à lui sont une invitation au voyage
je veux bien d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup
voyagé aussi les légendes
j'espère que ça donne envie aux veaux
d'aller voir ailleurs je m'aperçois
écouter boucle j'ai fait faire un monde
ça parle de cavage de raciste
les cuisines du monde puis quelque chose
comme ça qu'il nous fallait des thèmes
bbl maison de youtube mais qui me
convienne parfaitement dans le cadre de
la visite des lectures et ateliers
créatifs sont mises en place autour des
artistes jusqu'à la fin des vacances
scolaires avec un spectacle samedi 11
février en compagnie du chapiteau méli
mélo et pour notre rendez-vous juniors
on retrouve mélanie poquet et cette
semaine vous êtes partis au château de
breteuil à choisel pour des activités
couture oui c'est un atelier qui se
répète à chaque vacances scolaires mais
avec bien sûr camille un thème différent
pour ces vacances là sophie c'est la
responsable elle vous emmène à venise et
au carnaval plus exactement être quoi
l'aviation et des costumes et de la
couleur c'est génial et donc les enfants
sont invités à créer une partie de
costumes alors des couronnes des
chapeaux des prochaines des tutus
certains ont créé des ailes de papillons
des ailes de dragon moi j'en ai juste
certains c'est ma logique des choses et
c'est surtout ce qui est super
intéressant c'est qu'on peut utiliser
toutes les matières qui veut l'écouter
il commence à découper du carton par
exemple les formes de masse que les
formes de chapeau je réalise moi même
chaque format mon idée et les enfants
s'en servent comme un pochoir
ensuite il colle du tissu dessus il
décore en collant des paillettes des
plumes des perles des pompons des
pétales de fleurs en tissu alors
l'atelier s'adresse aux plus jeunes dès
4 ans mais aussi aux plus grands jusqu'à
14 ans
comment ça se déroule à ce que la
différence d'âge de battre autant trop
importante à la non déjà fait savoir
qu'elle est l'atelier est encadré par
deux adultes notamment sophie effet fait
date
à l'âge de l'enfant les pubs les plus
petits feront que du collage on va dire
les plus grands vont pouvoir travailler
avec des aiguilles du fils faire un bien
marcher leur imagination
certaines créations se font 30 minutes
certaines une heure voire deux à et les
enfants au final sur ses comptes en
écouter les j'avais vu un astérix obélix
mission angleterre et bah j'avais vu
plein de terre a été belle avec la
couronne et j'ai décidé d'en faire une
on a mis tout carton à avec la culture
après on a bien tenu et on m'a collé des
gommettes et des paillettes
je trouve que j'ai bien moi j'aime bien
ce qui est bien c'est que dans cet
atelier taf rampe apprend plein de
choses déjà bien de ça après du coup tu
peux ramener chez toi alors pour ce qui
est des informations pratiques les
parents vous pouvez déposer vos enfants
en fonction de leurs envies
s'ils veulent faire l'atelier et vous en
attendant vous allez visiter le château
l'atelier commence quand l'enfant arrive
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas d'horaires
fixes à respecter sauf 14h 17h30 qu'il
l'amplitude horaire de l'atelier s'est
ouvert tous les jours pour les tarifs
vous comptez 3 à 4 euros en fonction de
ce que veut réaliser l'enfant ça se
rajoute à l'entrée du château
mais comme je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure pas besoin de réservation et
bien bon merci beaucoup mais les ninjas
représenter ces ateliers costumes donc
on le rappelle a réalisé durant toutes
les vacances scolaires et pourquoi pas
une idée pour préparer mardi gras qui
arrive à la fin du mois et on passe
maintenant à notre agenda les autres
rendez vous à ne pas manquer
et on commence samedi dans le cadre de
l'exposition sur le textile à la
commanderie des templiers un atelier
scientifique est proposée ou proposés
pour les enfants dès 6 ans une activité
pour découvrir les étapes de coloration
d'un textile et élaboration des
teintures à base de végétaux et mercredi
ses pralines gay para qui s'occupe des
plus jeunes la conteuse dévoilera des
histoires à danser à rire et à chanter
qu'elle radidi donc rouler le loup et le
poussin et le chat et n'oubliez pas le
zoo de thoiry a rouvert ses portes
samedi dernier après la trêve hivernale
l'occasion d'aller découvrir les
nouveaux protégés nés ces derniers mois
notamment les bébés loutres et les
petites éoliennes qu'on voit à l'écran
le parc est ouvert du mercredi au
dimanche de 10h à 17h et c'est la fin de
ce set 8 loisirs merci de nous avoir
suivis je vous retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro je vous
souhaite un excellent week end
[Musique]